[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشهر الثامن من شهور السنه الهجريه يسمى
بشهر شعبان وسمي بهذا لتشعب غصون الاشجار
فيه ولتشعب الناس طلبا للمياه استعدادا
لموسم الصيف فهو يقع في زمن الربيع هذا
وقت التسميه وقيل لانه شعب اي ظهر بين رجب
المحرم ورمضان المقدس وقيل لتشعب القبائل
فيه طلبا للثائر والاقتتال بعد قعودهم عن
في شهر رجب المحرم وخلال شهر شعبان تم فرض
الصيام في السنه الثانيه من الهجره بعد
تحويل القبله من بيت المقدس الى مكه
المكرمه قد نرى تقلب وجهك في السماء فلا
نولينك قبله ترضاها فولي وجهك شطر مسجد
الحرامي وحيثما كنتم تول وجوهكم شطره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وشهر شعبان لهذه السنه في اوله جراند خامس
والذي يقال فيه جراند خامس ربيعا طامس وفي
منتصفه عقرب الدسم موسم عقرب الدسم وفي
نهايته موسم خروج الحشرات والزواحف
والهواء مسامه العقارب والثعابين واهل
الشام يقولون في سعد الخبايا
تطلع الحياه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]